hey guys I'm for hey I'm dress forgotten
for saying yeah you only read a book and
a half we're gonna check out the final
trailer for insurgent wait what if I
give something away
oh no she's all reading the book right
now
that's too bad baby I'm sorry I ran the
first one after I watched every turn of
course and then now I'm reading someone
and I'm only like five pages into it
it's so good
oh that's wonderful to hear I will so
consider reading this one day
you're living proof that the divergent
has grown beyond all control
- water - here
so now we're on official fugitives
divergents will destroy our society kill
them both
we have to stop her together
this is the only chance we have to
rescue a little civilization no pressure
times call for extreme measures
she's never gonna stop coming after us
the divergent series insurgent rated
pg-13 experience in and I'm actually
more 20th can we see you tonight max I
just returned the tickets
you had 3d tickets yeah man I feel
really bad why did he give in you know
we talked about it before we move in
together about situations where you felt
like you wouldn't want to have to help
me out with money well know if it's
something that we're both going to I
know but that's not like something
important like that's something I just
this movie looks incredibly cheesy I
don't feel like I can take this
seriously which is okay like I think
that will make the experience that much
better is how cheesy the acting is how
cheesy the lines of her she's fast
dude it's from a young adult novel that
is mostly the audience are females you
know young girls so is the Hunger Games
me which is a much better movie trailer
you know yet
I mean I don't know I stopped it first
this looks like you'd be faster paced in
which I like the first one I thought was
fun and I think this one's gonna be fun
too it doesn't look like bad cheese
these [ __ ] kids we are never having
children
we have Serbian okay time I'm sure I'll
have fun we already seen several of
these trailers not much more I can say
I haven't seen all of them only seem
like this this short short really
distracting I've only seen like the
short trailer so this is the first time
I've seen like a long one
you know we should do we should come
come huh you know we should do what we
shake combat the children are noises
with a dull noises yeah maybe then
they'll probably go away
you know just go out there with your
shirt off
yeah getting quieter there's a swarm of
children outside our apartment this is
not an apartment this is a full-blown
studio with an apartment set right it's
ridiculous the crew keeps bringing their
kids on set just really in character
right now oh yeah can you tell about you
saying that if you're new to the channel
you can subscribe to the real rejects
veronica has a music and vlog channel
you should check that out and you can
follow us both on Instagram and Twitter
and Facebook - yeah that's me on the
Twitter's we're fun I'm an Instagram
kind of person me too Twitter sucks yeah